depuis dimanche les tensions politiques
à jcs la capitale port au prince
en cause un désaccord sur la date de la
fin du mandat de jouvenel moïse selon
les manifestants le président haïtien de
très impopulaires
or et outrepasser la date du 7 février
supposé marquer la clôture officielle de
son mandat
ce lundi l'opposition à engager un bras
de fer avec le chef de l'état en
déclarant le juge de la cour suprême
joseph mécène jean louis président par
intérim qui est madame louise fini tout
le monde veut voir que le mandat du
président est terminée et les profits
juste de l'absence du parlement par
conséquent le président ne peut rien
faire même s'ils concluent des accords
politiciens aucun c'est son mandat qui a
pris fin ces mandats joël moïse qui
finit bien la cargaison
aujourd'hui j'ai vu comment ils nous ont
massacrés avec des gaz lacrymogènes la
population nous a dit que le mandat de
jovenna elle est terminée nous ne
quitterons pas les rues avant qu'il
n'ait quitté le pouvoir
manifestants et forces de l'ordre
s'affrontent depuis deux jours dans la
capitale haïtienne les jets de pierres
répondant aux tirs de grenades
lacrymogènes au total 23 personnes ont
été arrêtées depuis dimanche selon les
autorités et deux journalistes auraient
été blessées par balle selon des témoins
interrogés par la lfp
si les manifestants restent déterminés à
pousser je venais louise au départ pour
les autorités ces manifestations
constituent une tentative de coup d'état
je ne suis pas un dictateur
les dictateurs sont des gens qui
prennent le pouvoir et ne savent pas
quand ils vont partir je sais que mon
mandat prend fin le 7 février 2022 ce
désaccord sur la date est née du fait
que le chef d'état haïtien avait été élu
pour cinq ans fin 2015
mais le scrutin avait été annulé pour
fraude et joe venail moïse réélu un an
plus tard il avait prêté serment le 7
février 2017 et considère donc que son
mandat a commencé à cette date là c'est
également ce qu'a affirmé le porte
parole de l'onu
ces deux jours de violences découle
d'une longue crise politique depuis un
an haïti est privé de parlement josé del
moïse gouverne donc par décret
alimentant un peu plus la défiance de la
population à son égard